he's Clayton Custer the loyal to
shooting guard as the Loyola team the
Ramblers lose to Michigan over the
weekend and Clayton joins us now Clayton
where are you today I'm back in Chicago
back on campus how do you feel I mean
obviously we we wish that uh we had
another game tonight but we're
definitely proud of what we did this
year and I think we inspired a lot of
people across the country when did you
know you were in trouble against
Michigan um I don't know when all year
when when we've been ahead I think we
were undefeated this all year when we've
been up and half-time and so this game
and I don't know usually when teams make
a run we we do a pretty good job of kind
of locking in and settling in and and
stopping the run but um I don't know we
couldn't stop the bleeding and obviously
vogner had a couple threes there that
were daggers for us and we just didn't
have it that day or that night and I
don't know anyway it was it was
definitely frustrating but but we're
there was definitely a really cool
experience for all of us who do you
think wins tonight I mean if I had a guy
i mean Villanova looks really really
good if they should if they shoot the
ball the way they if they shouldn't have
as good as they shot it against Kansas I
mean they're gonna be a tough team to
beat and I would definitely have to pick
Villanova if I had to pick a team to win
tonight what was going on and all those
timeouts being called second half I mean
we were just trying to get we were
making some uncharacteristic mistakes so
we that we usually don't make we've been
so good all year at locking down the
defensive end and guarding things the
way that we want to guard them according
to the game plan and we were just making
some mental mistakes on our rotations we
were obviously vogner shot a bunch of
wide open threes which is not what you
want and I don't know we're just trying
to get get locked back in coach was
getting on us because we weren't doing
we were supposed to do but
yeah I mean it's a credit to Michigan
they're really good team and they
deserve to be where they're at you know
it's weird you know when I had you on
last week and you know everything's
great you're going the final four and
all the positive you know and everybody
you know slapping you and hey you know
this is wonderful I always worry that
when when something happens like this
with a great story and then it ends that
you know you feel bad and and I know you
do but you know the what you guys
accomplished you can't let that you
can't let these feelings today override
the bigger picture here with that ya
know I think you're right I mean
obviously we were we were pretty
emotional after right after the game and
we were sad that it was over and kind of
I think some of us were a little angry
that we that we didn't do what we were
supposed to do to win the game but I
mean I think it a few hours after the
game I think we all kind of got to sit
down and really soak in what we did and
the tears and the anger kind of turned
into a prideful feeling and and we were
definitely happy that we did what we did
for sure
ten years from now if I'm talking to you
the one moment memory you're gonna have
of this year's NCAA tournament is what
if I said you can only have one what
would it be I mean for me it was just
that celebration after that we wanted
the Elite Eight to go to the Final Four
I mean that that was a moment that uh
that that will change all of our lives
for a long time and to do it with this
group of guys was special just because I
think we we do everything the right way
in our organization we have such good
character guys on our team and just
being able to celebrate all the hard
work together in that moment after we
won the Elite Eight game that was
probably the biggest one for me will you
watch the game tonight yeah yeah I'll
for sure what I mean like I'm a
basketball fan I love basketball so I
got to watch the game tonight how good
will this team be next year I mean we
should we should be really good next
year I mean we've got a lot of pieces
coming back obviously we lose a lot too
we we lose Ben and Dante and Andre but I
mean we also bring back
four or five six of our top guys so I
mean I think we have a bright future
here and I'm excited to see what we can
do
that means more shots for you next year
I think we'll see about that when we've
stayed in the same hotel as you guys in
San Antonio at the Westin and I'm seeing
these like there's huge posters like
20-foot posters what's going through
your mind when you see yourself on a you
know on side of the Westin Hotel and
it's you yeah it was it was really cool
I don't think any of us really expected
all that we didn't know what is gonna be
like when we got there and especially
for us coming from Loyola we I mean we
haven't really experienced anything like
that you know what I mean it was cool to
see our big Fathead poster things up on
the up on the walls and stuff and do you
get too many but definitely did you ask
yeah that's what we that's what we we
were asking I think they might be
shipping those out shipping those back
to us here in Chicago because we are we
were all on we were on our assistants
and stuff about trying to get us we
definitely want to put one of those in
our and in my apartment for sure wait
wait your walls aren't big enough for
that platon well the one the one on the
outside of the the ones outside were way
way too big for that but they were like
you know like the little there were some
littler ones in the in the lobby and
stuff that I think we should sit on our
wall did you keep any souvenirs from
this run I mean the final floor does
such a good job of giving you a lot of
cool things I mean everyone who plays in
the Final Four gets one of the chairs
like one of the bench chairs it has the
final floor logo on it which is really
cool
they give everybody an official final
four ball with the final four logo on it
so I mean there's some cool things that
we all get and I'll definitely cherish
those for the rest of my life are you
allowed to keep your Jersey I'm hoping
we get to keep our Jersey I don't know
how it works we might have to use our
jerseys again next year I'm not sure but
uh
I kind of hope I kind of hopefully get
new jersey so that I can keep the Jersey
with the final four patch on it which is
uh which is really cool are you keeping
your coach well that's that's enough we
definitely hope so that we definitely
hope so
III can get you the Jersey I don't know
if I can keep you know coach coach there
I you know this is what happens with
success that you know he maybe he goes
to another another job I don't know
hopefully not but you know that's
usually what happens in these situations
so Clayton yeah yeah I know I know I
know how the business works but uh I
mean obviously I'm gonna do whatever I
can and we're all gonna do whatever we
can to keep him here and but I mean
obviously we support coach no matter
what but we're selfless as he won't want
to keep playing for him so that's what
we're gonna do whatever we can to do
that most famous person you met during
this whole tournament run hmm I don't
know for us for me I don't know I'm a
big golf guy so getting to talk to Jim
Nantz was really really cool for me just
hearing his voice and stuff like that
was cool for me
hearing him say we had him say a
tradition like unlike any other stuff
and it was pretty funny
so that was it going for me that's good
that's good hey it was a lot of fun and
once again I know you're bummed I know
you're down but you guys you change
college basketball at least for a month
that's pretty incredible what you guys
did so enjoy it and never forget it and
always think of the positives here
Clayton we will we will for sure thank
you so much
that's a Clayton Custer Loyola guard had
15 in the loss against Michigan four
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
you